our next speaker is lynn chen lynch
completed his phd from yale university
and he is currently a jp morgan research
fellow
in the reinforcement learning program
then
hi everybody i'm lynn um
uh my top ticket today is deep neural
intended kernel and laplace kernel have
the same rk edges and uh
uh we posted i'll have preprint here
next slide thank you okay
the main result is restricted to the
sphere uh
reload neural tangent kernel and the
laplace kernel have the same rkhs
and the main tool that i use here is
complex analysis
and we need to extend ntk to complex
numbers
and in the figure you can see a five
five layer ndk on a complex plane and
i only illustrate the imaginary part and
the slot here is the branch cut and let
me show you how
uh briefly how i do this next slide
thank you
okay so uh what's the neuro tender
kernel uh
jacob 2018 uh found that gradient photo
normally initialized fully connecting
neural net with the linear output layer
in the infinite width limit it's
equivalent to the
kernel regression with respect to the
ntk
next slide thank you
okay uh so first of all uh we found that
regular ndk
is the actual inner product kernel and
we use u to denote the
prod interface between x and y and we
have a very simple
uh we found a very significant
expression for right mdk
and involves arc cosine kernel
kernels of degree zero and one uh
in case the red will indicate with
k layers next slide thank you
okay so our high level strategy is to
compare
uh power power series coefficients of
laplace kernel and the power
and the ntk and uh
we use z to the uh n
k z to denote the uh ends power series
coefficients of the
kernel k and we i will show that
uh those ndk and laplace kernel
um the the power series coefficients of
both kernels
uh is n to the three halves
and we'll use the inclusion theorem here
uh the rths of k2 is larger than k1 if
there is a constant positive
constant such that c times k2 minus ky
is a positive definite kernel
uh next slide thank you
uh the main tool to analyze the power
series coefficients is analytic
combinatorics uh
the philosophy is the rate of the power
series on the
complex plane is determined by the local
asymptote around the dominant
singularities uh i mean the singularity
is
closest to zero uh next slide thank you
okay so uh if there is only one
singularity
uh we first of all we to use this tool
first we need to show that it
uh satisfy the kind of analytic
condition we call it
delta analytic and uh if we know that
the asymptotics is approximately one
minus z to the minus
alpha uh we know that the k
ns coefficient is approximately n to the
alpha minus one
and if there are multiple singularities
the influence of each dominant
singularity is added up
uh next slide thank you
okay so we need to extend ndk rail and
decay
to uh to the complex plane so we
only need to extend k k 0 and k 1 to
the compass plane and the branch cut is
-1 to 1
1 to infinity uh next slide thank you
so uh there there might be some work to
prove that
indicates it's uh meets the analytic
condition
uh it might be a little bit complicated
next slide
the essential around minus one one is
pretty simple
uh next slide
yeah so uh using the tools that we
mentioned here we can show that
both kernels have uh
power series coefficients of order n to
the three halves and
using this method can show that uh
maintain take away message
uh research the sphere red ntk and the
laplace current i have to sing okay
edges
if you have any questions just ask me
break a section thank you